for whatever reason that's why I'm
saying when God is within the
relationship and he's able to heal
things it makes him become possibly
understanding of the woman I'm not
saying this every man there are
anomalies as we've established yeah
one thing I will try and leave you on
this for me
women look at a man's future
which is exactly what you're saying
we're gonna look and heal to the Future
men are different men look at woman's
past because your past is going to
embarrass me in some way shape or form
and I need to admit that I need to
ensure paternity biologically so I'm
looking at a woman's past to see if she
can be within my future whereas you're
looking at my future
to see if I'm the right man that can
guide you in the right place you need to
be I mean I'm also looking into your
into your future but also into your past
because say for example I don't know say
I've met a man who he could I don't know
you could have had a kid somewhere I
need to know that that's not possible
okay
if I've had a kid what what as in like
if you've had a kid somewhere and you've
abandoned the kid I'm not going to want
to be with you all right so what about
if I tell you I've had a kid if you've
had a kid and you take care of your kid
and you do what you've got to do then
call
if you if you're if you're a man of God
you're faithful you're understanding you
provide you support you do what God has
called you to do
then what's wrong with that that's got
nothing to do with my past then
everything that after the the kid thing
is all about my future but your past as
well it plays into it all right my key
issue I can ignore the past if you have
if you do the right things in the future
or caveat about the past was based on
the fact that I hadn't I hadn't told you
something
um but my caveat is you may tell me
something and that is a deal breaker but
this is the thing everyone needs to look
into everyone's past because if you have
a past that's wild and you haven't tried
to sort it out it's going to creep up in
the future so like you might be let's
say a predator and you're like oh no I'm
good I'm good I'm good then you get with
someone then later on this person's seen
like yo why are you always looking at
this kid like what's wrong with you all
right girls you're using extreme no no
no she like you know what I'm saying
like she's right when you say look into
someone's past that's why you shouldn't
wife up a girl that's been ran through
like that's that's that's exactly like
she she just explained it to a t that's
why you don't do it okay so but then if
most girls have been ran through then
then there's nothing so does that mean
that the girls that have been ran
through don't deserve happiness at some
point of their life it's not about
deserving God deserves but what did they
earn it's like what it's it's like what
what do the men want and are they what
the men want so your philosophy is
basically women can't change so because
they can't change
you can't turn it home to a housewife
meaning she's not going to change her
past so because she can't change her
past meaning she's never going to be
good in the future so basically just
left her there and that's it you know
I'm telling you what men want and what
men say I'm just telling you what it is
I'm telling you this is how men view it
and men don't want to wife up hoes and
so and I'm not you know there's things
you can do to increase your market value
like you lose weight right you like
there's things you can do to like to up
your value to a guy and it doesn't mean
it's over for every hoe but in general
it's over for a lot of them that's why
you see 50 of women over 30 being single
and childless and it's they just proves
like the whole statement of this is a
man's world so in reality if we don't if
we don't oblige to what you ask or say
well you better fall in London
what the hell if you know it's a man it
works both ways like if I'm if I can't
provide for you you if I'm not being the
strong man you need me to be you're not
going to select me as a mating right now
you're not going to give me access to
sex like this works both ways this isn't
a one-sided argument no no I'm just
saying like there are conversations of
if she's a hoe then
yeah if she's home she there's
consequences to being a hoe yeah it's
not like she don't know that yeah I'm
pretty sure
that if women were told that hey this is
how men view it if you got five to I'll
say 12 5 to 12 bodies at a certain age
you are deemed as less valuable I think
less women would be in that bracket
but we're told and especially in the
church they say you can just apologize
later and you'll still get the same
husband you would have got at 22 and
that's just not true
you have to work for it it's not that
you can just like forget your past what
do they have to do they have to go to
Bible study and get back no it's a lot
of people a lot of people what are they
going to do a lot of people think is is
just that oh I can just
pray it away and I cannot
do the work that I need to do yeah
there's so this is something that I've
learned growing up they just said oh
pray pray pray and I don't acknowledge
what I need to do for myself because the
scripture says faith without works is
dead we have to do our part as well to
heal ourselves yes God will step in
where he needs to step in but if we
don't do our part we're going to be
broken and in the church there's going
to be a broken person and a broken
person coming together because they
think oh we're in the church we're fine
we're going to be able to live it up yes
I have a past but I'm okay I'm in the
church now I can do it and they never
dealt with what was back there that's
going to always come so a whole is
always going to be a hoe even if they
are in the church no matter if they're
there Faithfully every single Sunday if
they do not deal with what they have
done in the past they're going to be a
hoe when they marry the men they're
going to be a hoe at the end of their
life this is this is what I'm trying to
say about Soul repo it's literally like
it's for yourself it's not for the other
person once you do the work on yourself
you obey the word of God you listen to
the word of God you take it in you
understand it that's when you can heal
and that's when you will feel the true
healing well and I'm not talking about
internal though I'm not I'm saying but
your result even if you do the internal
healing and you're better the result is
men don't care in general the man the
men that the girls want the men with
options they don't they don't care they
just want to grow without a past so why
would they deal with a girl that's gone
through all this work of healing and did
all this stuff when they could just pick
the pretty 22 year old who has it you're
healing for yourself you're not healing
for that right so if you're healing for
yourself when you get to that man
whoever that man is that man really and
truly doesn't care about you he cares
about what you give him on face value
right and so if you're talking about oh
well I'm healing and blah blah blah like
Paul just said he may be like that may
be a little bit too much work like I
just go for the 23 year old who's like
just cool do you know what I mean it's
like the 23 year old could also be a hoe
and then no that she could be she could
be a a hoe but only have slept with in
that bracket before it gets to the
amount we're all deemed as so get that
she could be a hoe and slept with more
people than you but she's younger if
she's got fertility and then she's low
value no no no but no because it's it's
it's not just it's fertility too okay so
so they'll take a younger girl with more
bodies but if she's if she's hot and
she's she's 23 20 22 she can produce I
mean it's the same hood that you can't
housewife I mean at 30 she yeah there
was life on her once once once she gets
to 30 and she decides to do a Sierra and
she's board and she wants to twerk and
she wants to do this and then all of a
sudden oh she's now low value how many
men especially let's say rich men you
see dating younger girls actually wife
the younger girl like not a man in his
30s mid-30s going on 40 like probably
like okay let's say my 30